thousands of migrants are Crossing into
El Paso Texas each day so many in fact
that the city's mayor has declared a
state of emergency the scheduled end of
a pandemic era policy called title 42
this week could make things even worse
Omar villafranca is in El Paso for us
Omar good morning
good morning we are just outside the bus
depot here in El Paso it is below
freezing and migrants are sleeping
outside waiting for their bus and this
is exactly what local officials did not
want to happen that's why they've been
pleading with state and federal
officials for help saying that they do
not have the infrastructure to deal with
this influx of migrants and they are
saying if they don't get emergency help
more people will be left out in the cold
from wall to wall hundreds of people
crammed together at the border patrol
processing center in El Paso Texas taken
by Texas Congressman Tony Gonzalez shows
the extreme conditions inside a room
meant for 100 people now housing more
than 500. what I saw shocked me and I
wanted to share that with the world the
pandemic era policy known as title 42
allows for the immediate expulsion of
migrants over covid concerns and while
many Republicans have pushed back
against any coveted related policies
they've fought hard to keep title 42 in
place 19 republican-led States went to
court to challenge Wednesday's
expiration date but lost on Wednesday
our numbers go will go from 2500 to 4 5
or maybe six thousand the desperate
scene has spilled into downtown El Paso
shelters are at capacity and city blocks
are lined with huddled masses more than
a thousand people are estimated to be
sleeping outside in sub freezing
Sebastian is a social worker from
Colombia he says he received death
threats from gang members and was told
by authorities that they couldn't
guarantee his family's protection so he
fled with his wife and 11 month old
daughter
he says he planned to research the U.S
Asylum process but had to leave
immediately for their safety
the Biden Administration has been
scrambling for solutions they have to
have a policy of a orally Pathway to
Asylum through our bridges and if they
don't follow that pathway they need to
go back
El Paso is seeing a nearly 300 increase
in migrant Crossings compared to last
year and that has a ripple effect not
only here in the state but in other
cities outside of Texas New York's mayor
just said they may have to cut some
funding to City programs to deal with
the fact that they may be getting about
1 000 migrants a week Tony
Omar thank you very much